serious questions how old am I
i aged like seven years about two years
of zombie apocalypse time and at a much
faster rate than my sister do we have a
mutation of the Walker virus that causes
me to age quicker I'm gonna look like
Hershel when I'm 30
how come Rick gets all the credit for
the Rick and Carl meme I'm standing
right there but all you hear is Rick
this and Rick that takes two to meme
people the joke doesn't work without the
straight man also a way to turn the most
tragic moment of Karl's life into a
reddit cliche dicks how many resources
is the kingdom using to keep a tiger
alive I'm just saying when push comes to
shove I am NOT sharing pudding with that
tiger share with God who accidentally
gets shot twice I'm starting to think
that it's not really an accident there's
a sniper out there with a grudge and
he's a dick why doesn't he can keep
wearing that leather jacket nothing deep
here Atlanta just gets really humid it's
good
who taught everyone had a farm there's
no internet so you can't get help from
farmersonly.com we call them walkers so
we call them walkers because zombies
don't exist in our universes version of
pop culture right did our Michael
Jackson skip Halloween to drop a sick
Thanksgiving ain't them instead okay how
does Georgia just have a limited
gasoline we're never gonna get to the
cooled Mad Max phase of the apocalypse
at this rate who is cleaning up all the
water bodies and where are they taking
them and why whoever they are they're
probably really creepy
we should probably kill negan right yes
Oh Carl why does everyone think my dad
is weird for calling me coral it's my
name he named me after his favorite
basketball player coral Malone well when
this is all over we're taking a
snorkeling trip to the coral reef sobs
you